і чого ви так Чому ви так боїтеся цього
дракона Тим паче що українська армія вже
переламала йому ікла чомусь українці
викликає Роздратування Навальний та Хто
ти такий що на нашій території
проводитимеш свої референдуми нам Путін
сказав що все законно І що такий тупий
поки немає цієї товкутнечі треба швидко
залишати Крим
коли його привезуть в гагу А мене
запросять як свідка я скажу що і як було
добро пожалуй Ласкаво просимо до
програми в тренді на Deutsche Welle Дуже
приємно дякую
почнімо з призначення людини яку Ви
добре знаєте ростемо Умерова новим
міністром оборони України він працював з
вами був вашим помічником його
призначення важливе для
кримськотатарського народу адже
представник корінного народу отримує
таку посаду скажіть чого чекати від
умірова як міністра оборони
я його змалку знаю ще малим хлопцем дуже
талановитий молодець і головне дуже
порядний чесний І взагалі вся його
родина має велику повагу в Криму батько
брат
всётки это не все таки це не ті якості
які насамперед асоціюються з міністром
оборони країни що воює
військовими питаннями він почав
цікавитися вже після окупації Криму і
особливо після широкомасштабного
вторгнення Коли стало зрозуміло що Крим
звільняти дипломатичними методами і
немає перспектив і швидше за все буде
військове визволення
він зблизився з військовими з військовою
розвідкою
там розробляли деякі операції
[музика]
швидко звернули на нього увагу тому що
він дуже тямущий
крім того Він має великий зв’язки Він в
основному одразу ж зайнявся поставками
озброєння використовуючи свої зв'язки
насамперед в Туреччині Арабських країнах
та й у Європі Сполучених Штатах
Дивіться яка історія якщо ми подивимося
на всі ці країни Саудівської аравію
більшу частину Арабських країн скажімо
Туреччину яка маневрує між Україною та
Росією
України і Росії інші країни в
глобального півня всі вони займають в
очікувальну позицію по суті позицію
хорошого ставлення до Путіна це великий
виклик чи головне це захід
ного апреля этого года Зеленский давал
іфтар 7 квітня цього року під час
рамадану Зеленський взяв участь в
вівтарі для воїнів-мусульман в основному
це були Кримські татари і там були
запрошені посли мусульманських країн
виступав Він я виступав там теж лише ми
вдвох виступали і я сказав що ми дуже
вдячні всім країнам які допомагають нам
у цій тяжкі часи
зокрема ідея яким ісламським країнам
але відверто кажучи ми очікували на
більшу підтримку ісламських країн
я сказав таку річ яка викликала велику
реакцію Це коментували
я говорив що я не Богослов і не знаю
тонкощів ісламського права
але як рядовий мусульманин точно знає що
в ісламі не може бути нейтралітетом між
добром і злом
[музика]
між злочинцем і жертвою злочину
і чого ви так чого ви так боїтеся цього
дракона тим більше коли українська армія
зламала йому ікла
чому в нормальному мусульманам не
підтримати правильну сторону
Це дійсно так бо я дивлюся на генеральну
асамблею ООН в основному нас підтримують
західні держави
Я знайшов вашу розмову в 2021 році на
інтернет-сайті New Ways тоді ви говорили
що міжнародне співтовариство може
створити ситуацію коли Путіну буде нічим
годувати півтора мільйону армію особливо
каральні внутрішні війська адже ця
величезна за площею держава живе за
рахунок продажу природних в основному
нафтогазових ресурсів її ВВП малий якщо
на кілька місяців накласти на купівлю
природних ресурсів Росії відключити
банківську систему Swift То можна
побачити як скоро в Росії все почне
розсипатися дивіться Swift відключили
емберго запровадили Але хтось купує але
захід переорієнтувався з російських
енергоресурсів усе це сталося ще
Минулого року а я триває війна
продолжается
не получилось тотальний ембаргу не
вдалося так деякі країни західні країни
в основному наклали ембарго а інші
країни користуючись цим дешево стали
купляти енергоресурси скажімо Індія в 19
разів збільшила закупівлю нафтопродуктів
та нафти в Росії те саме Китай
Звісно це не те що вони в Європу
продавали Але тим не менш вони знаходять
лозівки до того ж Росія величезна
держава у неї великі природні ресурси
який з запасу У них є але те що було
завдано серйозного удару зламано хребет
російської економіки це вже ясно але
певний час вони ще звісно можуть
триматися
не только крымского Татарский Народ не
лише кримськотатарський народ а й
українське суспільство готові до
затяжної війни бо дивишся 40 мільйонів в
Росію живуть 35 в Україні демографічна
різниця в чотири рази очевидно Путін не
призове в усіх чоловіків на війну бо
комусь треба працювати але й в Україні
теж очевидно українці мотивовані краще
Вони захищають свою землю зброя краще
але Путін все одно буде кидати і кидати
людей на фронт чи готове до цього
суспільство в Україні на вашу думку
я вам сказав що я сказав би що після
повномасштабного вторгнення 24 лютого
суспільство в Україні дуже змінилося
воно дуже консолідувалося
і воно багато до чого готове
я не сказав про 100% громадян України
але переважна більшість буде готова до
багатьох жертв
адже іншого виходу немає ми ж бачимо що
робить Росія на окупованих територіях і
щоб взагалі буде якщо ми тут зазнаємо
поразки якщо захоплені Росією територією
залишаться під окупацією тому рішучість
українського народу на найвищому рівні
українського
народу
о
будущем поговоримо про майбутнє
окупованих територію поки облишимо Крим
людей які там живуть змушують брати
російські паспорти
вони змушені включатися в російські
документи обіг і так далі І так далі яке
ставлення має бути до них крім какое
отношение
по-перше паспорти ми не визнаємо
оскільки до того щоб людина вийшла з
українського громадянства їй потрібно
написати заяву
А те що під окупацією змушують ми це
розглядаємо як під німецькою окупацією
коли нацисти видавали аусвайси
тим не менше прийомі на роботу якщо
людина з окупованої території мала
паспорт російський це має значення
тому в якихось межах можуть не допустити
Хто знає що там відбулося на окупованій
території
є якісь чутливі роботи так
поліція чи щось типу такого
люди пов'язані з державною таємницею і
так далі руководство України керівництво
України з меджлісом із представником
президента у Криму та мілою ташевою
розробили цілий план з деокупації що
робити коли вона відбудеться
чи могли б ви розповісти які головні
пункти
делать там 23 пункти що і в якій сфері
робити так зокрема йдеться про те що
після окупації Криму
за нашими оцінками не менше мільйона
російських громадян завезли на територію
Кримського півострова
це буде для нас велика проблема але я
все ж сподіваюся що коли Українські
збройні сили заходитимуть їх уже не
будет
Як до речі за російськими даними їх
набагато менше
160-200 тисяч
це неправда навіть за ростом кількості
населення Севастополя воно збільшилося в
півтори рази
Сімферополя теж Сімферополь Це було б
дуже помітно крім не дуже великий там
була б щільність вищою
совершенные Люди там взагалі зараз
кажуть Сімферополь зовсім інші люди
начебто змінили місто повністю змінили
населення Ну ми звісно будемо там діяти
відповідно до українського законодавства
по-перше буде відповідальність за
незаконний в'їзд на територію України
там передбачається якийсь санкції
щоправда не пов'язані з ув'язненням
якийсь штрафи Але якщо ти зайшов зі
зброєю в руках То це до 8 років
позбавлення волі Я думаю розумно буде їм
ще до приходу наших військ скоріше
покинути Крим
тут обговорювалося питання чи
ліквідувати Кримський міст чи ні Бо ж
людям треба їхати
але є ще інший бік цього мосту цим
мостом надходять десь близько 30%
озброєнь
яким обстрілюється материкова частина
України
тому такий сходимося на думці що цей
міст треба ліквідувати
існує поромна переправа
просто люди повинні не чекати коли
почнеться втеча і стовпотворіння
я теж не раз сказав про це поки немає
цієї товкотнечі треба швидко залишати
Крим
і те саме стосується колаборантів
відверто кажучи
ми б не хотіли репресії але люди повинні
нести відповідальність за ті злочини які
вони робили
тому для них теж найкращий вихід так
далеко сховатися щоб ми не змогли їх
знайти бо після падіння путінського
режиму ми ж вимагатиме їх назад після
Даже если тобто навіть якщо оці
колаборанти поїдуть в Росію до
повернення
Ми повинні вимагати їх назад
від нового російського уряду так ну
щодо розуміємо що ці колаборанти мають
дітей родичів ці фактори
А что с этим делом А що з цим робити
уявляєте ви почнете виселяти їхні сім'ї
одразу прийдуть а внески International
Human right Watch правозахисні
організації усілякі скажуть як можете
виселяти людей Вони не несуть
відповідальності за політичну складову
вже за тією ознакою що незаконно в'їхали
вони підлягають депортації вони скажуть
що нічого не розуміли мовляв Путін
сказав що все законно ми нічого не знали
і приїхали
незнання закону не звільняє від
відповідальності ти чудово розумієш що
такий тупий увесь світ каже що це
незаконно окуповані території є
резолюції генеральної асамблеї ООН мало
що тобі Путін сказав німців які говорили
нам Гітлер сказав це не рятувало у
нюрнберзі всі посилалися на те що вони
виконували наказ але їх повісили тобто
буде Суворов принципово Обов'язково я
так понимаю что я так розумію що ваша
позиція - це так би мовити національна
територіальна автономія у Криму тобто по
простому кажучи це що ось для нашої
аудиторії Поясніть що головним на цій
землі кримськотатарський народ правильно
не головним тут просто мається на увазі
створення механізму захисту прав
кримськотатарського народу у тому
проєкті який ми подали і зараз
відправили на венеціанську комісію на
експертизу з погляду європейського права
щоб дали оцінку єдиним привілеєм для
кримських татар буде те що
кримськотатарська мова на території
Автономної республіки буде поряд із
офіційною мовою
з українською мовою
з українською
также принцип розробляється також
принцип представництво корінного народу
своєї території в обсязі щонайменше 33%
в органах влади в органах виконавчої
представницької судової влади ні то ось
такого
У вас немає такого відчуття Мустафа ага
що довгі роки українські політичний клас
до речі про цей іноді говорить і Путін А
вони не звертали уваги на Крим забули
про нього після 90-х років у вас немає
відчуття що українські політичні клас як
такий теж раптом про кримських татар
згадав тоді коли сталася окупація і
особливо в останні роки останнім часом
схаменулися тому що ви потрібні
Я думаю что украинская как государство
Украина як держава в повному розумінні
стала незалежною здебільшого лише після
революції гідності у 2014 році а до того
дуже був сильний вплив нашого сусіда
Я знаю у 2014 році ЦРУ повідомляло що
близько 30% таких важливих структур як
Міністерство оборони служба безпеки
прокуратура більше 30% була російська
агентура
у цій ситуації про Крим взагалі говорити
Нема чого
СБУ у Криму працювало проти нас як філія
ФСБ
справа Тут уже не в позиції України як
держави а саме у важелях якими
користувалися РФ щоб проводити свою
політику
Я пам'ятаю Ми ще 2011 року перехоплювали
одну аналітичну записку з Росії фсбну
щоправда не в безпосередньому викладі
та йшлося про те що основним противником
реалізації стратегічних інтересів РФ у
Криму є Кримські татари
їхні представницькі орган менжеліс і
тому пропонувалося заходи щодо боротьби
з цим
я хочу сказати Як поєднувалася позиція
СБУ і Росії за деякий час ми перехопили
аналітичну записку СБУ
вам її принесли чи що
вони стежили за нами ми за ними стежили
У нас теж своя була агентура тому ми
знали хто що робить щоб захищати свої
інтереси так от у ці аналітичній записці
записка СБУ
звітувала своєму начальству в Києві та
писала що основним противником існуючого
режиму режиму Януковича є Кримські
татари як під копірку як ослабитиме чи
ліс створити організації які
протистоятимуть меджилісу релігійні
спортивні жіночі Ось така ситуація була
синхрону на вашу думку працювала СБУ та
ФСБ у Криму не будемо далеко йти беремо
14-й рік ви казали що керівництво
України яке прийшло після Майдану мало
дати вказівки чинити опір Ви самі
описуєте ситуацію коли чинити опір було
практично нікому чи винні вони яценюки
всі решта в тому що Крим було втрачено
счаствую территорию твій обов’язок усіма
засобами захищати свою територію тому ми
її очікували що ось із Києва прозвучить
таке Батьківщина в небезпеці громадяни
до зброї але цього не було у Криму
наприклад були готові але в нас ні зброї
ні було ні головне сигналу
навпаки весь час Київ і наші союзники
посольства США Німеччина
говорили в жодному разі нічого не
провокуйте щоб як у Грузії у 2008 році
не звинуватили вас в екстремізмі не дали
виправдання діям російської збройних сил
на території Криму
сіл на території Криму А всі Опа всі
питання деокупації ми мовляв вирішимо
дипломатичним шляхом така була позиція
Але я думаю що якби почалися військові
дії звичайно Було б кровопролиття але
по-перше там би росіяни і залишилися
вони в Донбас не захоплювали
Ну ви самі говорили в 14-м году але ви
самі казали в 2014 році Якщо Путін зайде
до Криму то це може бути друга Чечня але
другої Чечні не сталося у Криму я говорю
что мы же я колись Путіним разговаривал
я колись Путіним розмовляв телефоном Він
мені розповідав що ось ми знаємо ви
суворо дотримуєтеся принципу не
насильства
сподіваюся що не буде зіткнень між
кримськими татарами та нашими збройними
силами у Криму
Я йому сказав що принцип не насильства
це для досягнення своїх громадянських
прав у своїй державі А коли наступає
Чужий чобіт - це зовсім інші принципи
коли я відразу сказав що ми як Кримські
татари не збираємося воювати з Росією
у нас не те співвідношення сил але як
громадяни України ми робитимемо те що
вирішать у Києві
ми дійсно очікували від Києва якихось
вказівок
часто запитують Чому Кримські татари не
розпочали партизанську війну у різних
ток-шоу
Я не люблю різко говорити але тут я не
втримався і сказав
тому що Українські збройні сили свою
зброю здавали на Кримським татарам а
росіянам
ось ці збройні сили які мали розпочати
військові дії А ми що зовсім без збройні
що ви від нас очікуєте тоді ж взагалі
найвищим проявом патріотизму було
заспівати український гімн та віддати
зброю росіянам що це за ставлення до
окупантів
і Це деморалізуюча вплинуло на багатьох
вони і зброю в руках нічого не роблять
як же ми можемо без зброї йти проти
окупантів
ви як вважаєте ось те що було потім
скажімо політика Порошенка укладання
мінських домовленостей це було правильно
чи треба було можливо активніше чинити
опір тоді Порошенко взагалі ввів
правильну політику у тому плані що почав
знову створювати Українські збройні сили
та на момент виборів у 19-му році вже в
нас були збройні сили
Зеленський как президент Зеленський як
президент ніхто не очікував що він так
себе проявить перетвориться на
військового лідера лідера військової
пори і так далі Ось Він говорить
сьогодні ми не відступимо Доки не
повернемо кордони
1991 року включно з Кримом на вашу думку
у нього в українського керівництва
вистачить На це сил уніву
про те що поступитися територією
рівнозначні державній зраді і взагалі є
указ Президента про те що жодних
переговорів з Путіним і з режимом Путіна
бути не може
це після їхніх звір з у Бучі і в інших
місцях
тому я не думаю що хтось наважиться
сказати давайте пожертвуємо якоїсь своєю
територією
представим себе что война завершилась из
Возвращение всех территорий уявімо що
війна завершилася поверненням всіх
територій починається мирно облаштування
життя
[музика]
і вам Як лідеру кримськотатарського
Народу кажуть ну знаєте все-таки держава
в нас унітарна а не федеративна які нам
автономії
Ви впевнені що всі обіцянки
кримськотатарського народу будуть
виконані Українською Державою
ніхто нам не даёт но таких обіцянок
ніхто нам не дає але я знаю що якщо до
цих подій до окупації Криму
особливо до повномасштабного вторгнення
наші законні вимоги щодо відновлення
національної та територіальної автономії
підтримували десь 20%. зараз десь
55-60% підтримують тобто розуміння
важливості цього питання в Україні такий
зростає незалежність
уявимо Путін помер так сталося
приходять інші люди до влади які можливо
не хочуть продовжувати цю війну але це
люди з того самого режиму
і ось вони починають через посередників
виходити на український народ і говорити
Давайте поспілкуємося як вирішити це
питання якщо ми зараз віддамо все ми
просто впадемо і тоді нам краще
продовжувати війну
ось із цим пост путінським режимом треба
мати справу
пост Путіна
рух підемо чи не впадемо це їхні
проблеми нас це не турбує турбує але
відносно ми поговоримо лише після того
як останній солдат покине наше територію
до цього жодних розмов не буде
чи потрібно нинішній Українській державі
суспільству мати справу з російською
опозицією як ви на неї дивитеся
опозиція різношерста чомусь українці
викликає Роздратування Навальний Хоча
він начебто головний супротивник Путіна
він одну дурість сказав хоча наче
останнім часом дав задню сказав що Крим
це не бутерброд щоб просто так повернути
Хоча він казав що це вирвано із
контексту
там чесний такої референдум Він сказав
що треба провести там чесний референдум
та Хто ти такий що на нашій території
проводитиме і референдуми ти там у себе
у воронжі Проведи дурість звісно для
Політика - це непробачна дурість але він
це вже Наскільки я розумію усвідомив і
вже інакше зараз говорить про Крим
говорить що безумовно треба звільняти
його та повертати до складу Української
держави
ви згадали ще одну річ як ви говорили з
Путіним він намагався купити вашу
лояльність
в основному Він обіцяв якісь блага для
вирішення У нього такий вислів був що ми
російська держава багата велика могутня
за кілька місяців зробимо більше ніж
незалежна українська держава зробила за
свої 23 роки Незалежності
соціальні політичні правові питання
кримськотатарського народу вирішимо
закінчилося тим що він сказав що цей
телефон відкритий будь-який час коли
захочете Зв'яжіться зі мною
Можливо колись зателефонуєте
Можливо коли його привезуть в гагу А
мене запросять як свідко я скажу що і як
було що він говорив І що він потім робив
коли ви думаєте що повернетеся до Криму
якби не було підриву Каховського
водосховища ми вже там були Я не думав
що путінський режим піде на таку
підлість але якщо не цього року то
наступного На мою думку ми будемо в
Криму Мустафа Джемілєв Велике спасибі за
інтерв'ю дякую вам
[музика]